[Music]
so significance of this area for me as a
child I was brought up here
family would come out seasonal periods
and live on the river in the eastery
gathering my hunger chi most people were
unaware that we have a lot of rare birds
here in not only rare that are in
decline it's been roughly nearly 70 bird
species reported
and around the history here there are
about 12 endemic species that can be
seen here for us it's it is important
that
it is protected so the bottle has just
been changed for the history in this
area - it's a no dog zone and also we've
put in place for no vehicle access and
to the street we patrol week in Li and
weekly to just try and combat against
anyone that it's not up to fate with the
changing finals for the vehicles in
these people yeah I think for a lot of
them it is just education they Dave pets
realized what damage they're doing it's
like everywhere you go
90 no I'm seeing that the public are
really good it's just at one Sydney
they've times very out there to to be
disruptive and this with the local
communities really take they jump on
board with the new bylaws them that will
hit a apart
put through the process of the bottle
has been put in place so when they see
something happening in their area their
patch they will give us a call and we'll
come down
situation
[Music]
you